Якщо спиратися на повідомлені випадки, то
близько 2-3 %. Але, можливо, нижче, тому що
все ще є незафіксовані випадки.
Переважно літні люди, люди з іншими захворюваннями,
серцевою недостатністю, діабетом, раком та хворобами легенів.
Зазвичай все починається з респіраторної інфекції,
яку можна порівняти зі звичайною застудою.
Це триватиме в більшості випадків близько тижня,
і 80-85 % пацієнтів одужують.
Однак певна кількість випадків мають другу,
складнішу фазу, коли у пацієнта розвивається
пневмонія або легенева інфекція.
Але це у меншості випадків.
Треба закривати рот і ніс серветкою, якщо ви
кашляєте або чхаєте. Викиньте цю серветку
і помийте руки. А якщо у вас немає серветки,
використовуйте лікоть. Дуже важливо часто мити руки.
Тримайтеся на певній відстані від людей довкола вас.
Що ми не рекомендуємо, так це використання медичних масок
у повсякденному житті або коли ви на вулиці.
Немає наукового підтвердження, що це дієвий засіб захисту.
Перша проблема: що робити з людьми всередині міста?
Треба відстежувати контакти і відокремлювати пацієнтів
від здорових людей. Навіть у місті, яке перебуває на карантині.
Друга проблема: треба приблизно уявляти собі,
коли це "закриття" міста повинно бути знятим.
Коли трапляється контакт між пацієнтами
і здоровими людьми всередині карантину, то
відрахунок часу ізоляції - з наукового погляду -
слід запускати заново. Але не можна ізолювати
місто від зовнішнього світу на тижні або місяці.
Такими заходами ви створюєте набагато більше проблем, ніж вирішуєте.